Now the NAT clearly violates the end-to-end principle,
because machines behind the NAT are not globally
addressable, or routable, and other hosts on the
public Internet cannot initiate inbound connections to these devices
behind the NAT. Now there are ways to
get around this, they're various protocols. One is called
STUN, or signalling and tunneling through UDP-enabled NAT
devices. And in these types of protocols, the device
sends an initial outbound packet somewhere, simply to
create an entry in the NAT table and
once that entry is created. We now have
a globally routable address and port to which devices
on a public Internet can send traffic. Now
these devices somehow have to learn that public IP
address and port that corresponds to that service
and this might be done using DNS for example.
It's also possible to statically configure, these tunnels
or mappings on your NAT device at home.
Needless to say, even with these types of
hacks and workarounds for NAT, it's clear that network
address translation is a violation of the end-to-end
principle. Because by default two hosts on the
Internet, one on the home network and one
on the public Internet, cannot communicate directly by default.